万万没想到将OBV指标的参数设定为42
抓主声浪抓一次准一次
而且炒股这13年来屡次不爽
大家好我是你们的老陈
今天给大家分享OBV指标修改参数后的九大用法和实战技巧
那么对于OBV指标啊
相信很多人都了解过
它被誉为啊这个能量潮的缩减形式
能清晰反映出成交量的进额数值
一眼就能看出后续股票的强弱表现
那具体怎么用的呢
点个赞支持一下
我们直接来讲实战案例
包括视频的最后
老生还给大家总结了一份详细的使用方法
分为六个口诀
非常的好记
新手小白也能看懂
那么在开始之前
我们先要将这个OBV的指标
进行一个参数设定
那么打开我们的交易盘面之后
随便打开一只股票
点开它的K线图
在下方这个指标栏当中找到OBV指标
然后点击鼠标左键
然后选择鼠标右键
选择右下角的修改指标参数
那么这个时候我们就可以看到
他默认的参数是30对吧
那么我们把它调为42点击确定就可以了
那么参数设定之后
我们直接来看OBV这个指标的第一大使用技巧
股价与OBV指标同步横盘震荡之后
然后股价缓慢拉伸的途中
这个股价在调整的过程当中
然后与这个 obv 的指标线形成背移的话那么这个位置就是我们的一个入场点也就是obv指标与这个股价形成背移的时候
那么这个时候说明
股价还将继续攀升
第二大用法
obv指标开启上涨趋势
结果股价呈现一个下降趋势
那么此时就说明
这个主力资金在打压股价
在这个区间内主力就在吸筹
那么一旦主力吸筹完毕之后
那么obv指标加速朝上的话
就表示后期即将开启主声浪
第三大技巧
股价与obv持续在横盘震荡过后
然后突然突破了箱体的位置
那么表示股价即将快速拉伸
也就是突破这一个obv的箱体的时候
就是一个买入的信号
第四大技巧
比如说股票在横盘震荡之后
在箱体
然后跌破了箱体的时候
那么下方OBV与这一个股价形成了一个背离
也就是股价往下调整
那么OBV的指标是往上进行拉伸的
那么这个时候就说明有阻力在朝底了
那么此时也是我们的一个入场的时机
上车之后我们可以发现
股价同样也开启了一波持续的拉伸
第五大技巧 也就是obv指标
呈现出一个增减的这种形式
然后股价却在持续的打压下降
同样也说明这个时候在这个位置
是有人在进行抄底的那么这种形态也是一个积极做多的信号第六大技巧啊股价在一波拉伸之后那么 obv 同样也在进行持续的拉伸
然后经过一波横盘震荡之后呢
股价突破了啊前期的一个新高
然后呢
这个 obv 的指标同样也创出了这一个新高的位置
第六大技巧
股价开启了一波拉伸
同样 obv 指标呢
也是同样同步的进行拉升
结果在一波横盘震荡之后
下方obv指标呢
创出了前面的一个新高
但是呢上方股价
它并没有创出新高
这说明啊
是一个主力正在出货的迹象
此时就是我们的一个离场时机
后续啊
我们可以看到
股价在持续的进行一个下降了
第七大技巧啊
这个obv指标的量能
它的需求在不断的增大
我们可以看到他的这一个高点
是在持续的进行创新高
对吧
但是股价他却没有一点变化
而是在横盘震荡
此时就说明主力在对销出货
那么出现这种情况
我们一定要抓紧时间进行离场
不然后续就是一波大幅的下沙
第八个OBOA跟股价都在持续的缓慢
进行拉升
也就是他表现为持续的上涨
说明量价其身后续还有上涨的空间
可以进行逢低加仓
最后一个第九个技巧
也就是下方 obv指标
他创出了新高
上方股价的话还在持续走低
股价不创新高那么这个时候就说明他的一个需求量暴增但是股价没有跟上说明阻力它在对销出货当后面这个股价与obv指标形成背离的时候
那么我们一定要赶紧的立场
表示后续还有一波下杀
好最后我们来看obv的六大使用技巧
大家可以记一下
如果记性不太好的朋友也可以截图保存一下
那么我们来看第一个股价上升
OBV线下降表示买方无力
股价要回调
第二个股价下降
OBV线上升表示买方旺盛
股价还要上升
第三个OBV线缓慢上升
买方力量逐渐增强
表示是一个入场的金号
第四个股价双重顶还没有形成的时候
股价再一次涨到前期高点
如果OBV线同步
则表示股价继续上涨
反之的话
OBV形成一个顶背离的话
确认股价双重顶为一个卖出的信号
第五个
OBV线从正数转为负数为下跌趋势
此时就要及时的离场
反之OBV线从负数转为正数
则是一个进场的时期
第六个OBV线最大的用处就是
长时间整理之后脱离盘整
就会选择出一个新的方向
如果它后续是向上的
那么我们就可以进行一个上车
如果是向下的呢
我们一定要进行及时的离场
那以上就是关于OBO指标的九大用法
和六个技巧了
看完觉得有收获的朋友
在评论区给我打上三个八支持一下
我是崇尔德顿鼓
我们下期视频再见